here's good vs is pitiful yeah you bros
submitted over a hundred pages of fine
art last week I'm announcing a new
competition by the end of this video so
don't miss it
these are the winners I am so excited to
see what you bros have made you had over
a week to create so I expect some pretty
cool stuff so let's start what the [ __ ]
is this this is the most beautiful art I
have ever seen in my life
ayyy boobs know this is a great idea I'm
so glad I came up with this this is what
happens when pewds smoke weed how the
[ __ ] do you know that
why do you bros want me to get a chronic
disease what the [ __ ] is this
what hey look at that
beautiful that's stunning
why am i hands dicks that one's pretty
cute
alright kauai last time I checked I'm
not 84 years old don't just [ __ ] take
a picture and then put a [ __ ] shitty
Photoshop filter on it and say you drew
it whoa okay very erotic if you look
closely you can actually see that this
photo is not Photoshop man the amount of
detailing it's [ __ ] amazing no no no
okay that's pretty cool is that me
winning over Dylan to hacker
that's what's gonna happen Dylan how
dare you hey
anime hey hey oh gosh hey this is pretty
cool
my eyebrows look like the mustache of
Steve Harvey well at least you're honest
hey that's awesome very kawaii you think
you're funny
hey this is amazing this is 2011 Peter
pie where I actually look [ __ ] hot as
[ __ ] look at me now oh my god
this one looks real that's amazing that
one brofist man Wow
you really captured my nose and my
golden teeth some of these are actually
really talented I'm really impressed
this one is not it I'm sorry put it by
sucks for PewDiePie oh hello hello hello
there
now we're talking oh my god is this
getting too hot [ __ ] is this what the
hell am I looking at here why do you
draw hair on my feet nice ass I can't
tell if that's that's my balls or my ass
but either way it's good you know it's
good don't worry about it oh yes we
found it guys oh alright
we've dabbled into furry section pitty
Pat McConahay now this that's muscle
goes I love the one punishment one no I
can do it
hey gravity falls
[ __ ] yeah that's awesome whoa what the
hell is this that's so cool
okay that one's cool that was [ __ ]
cool I don't know why you guys like
attacking the Titans so damn much
play-doh pie what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you that's beautiful
it's beautiful man Wow just just wow
honestly
holy [ __ ] what - Shh what the [ __ ]
she even added in an ass tattoo oh hello
Oh gets better
oh my god that's mean fault that totally
looks like me what what [ __ ]
ah that's creepy sent me on a pregnant
lady with the why am i a mermaid and why
am I so into it
hey that's [ __ ] awesome blood-borne
baby I have two questions why and why
and please kill me what's hiding in
Piers beard the entirety of Ikea all the
unmade PD cry video Edgar's discipline
yeah though that doesn't even exist now
for [ __ ] sake
why sir t-rex and why do I have a
vibrating butt plug zero depth that's
awesome
oh that's so cool they added like all
the series and references I love I love
stuff like this that's so cool this took
me like five minutes I'm surprised I
took you five minutes I can do that in
five seconds alright this is just like
what the [ __ ] is going on in your head
oh that's [ __ ] awesome hell yeah
thanks for not making me bald as well I
appreciate that pop or deep eye it took
me a while
that was my wife Tammy what that what i
8p d pi PD PI's socks oh they're trying
to tell me I have a big head are you
telling are you trying to tell me
YouTube has gone to my head Oh
yeah yeah I look like Matthew
McConaughey [ __ ] you yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome that's so [ __ ] cool I'm like
it I like it I'm sorry bro I'm never
going to shave this fabulous beard of
mine
nope never see this is what I'm going
for
oh my God why would you whoa that's
awesome
some of these are so cool all I wanted
with me and my sis out Gayle god damnit
parents not again
why does Edgar have a big of what the
[ __ ] equator what kind of tiny little
nub thing is this what the hell are you
trying to tell me man why is my left arm
bigger than the other one what are you
trying to tell me every rain press X -
Edgar Edgar step out of my way Edgar
this is awesome - Edgar what the [ __ ] is
this
oh it's Edgar Pete wow that's cool hey
that's awesome and that's the proof
that's a pro fish whoa
these are awesome dude that's so cool
I'm gonna save this why what's with all
the remnant it's because of the beard
yes that's the kiss of the beat oh yes
the winner of course before and after
fabulae sir oh my god there we go again
oh hello what happened dear
undertale that's awesome I love it whoa
what the [ __ ] why do I look so vicious
oh it's a little booty pop bracelet
that's awesome
oh my god that's so cool that's so
pretty oh damn I am thank you Jesus
we're getting to some really good ones
oh my god
Jesus that's so creepy
[Laughter]
yeah Viking parents [ __ ] yeah
that's awesome
solidest that's cool Xaro damn bros for
[ __ ] sake
what does it's for the live stream
[Music]
[ __ ] badass man hell yes ah that's
awesome
oh it's all undertale PewDiePie and a
pug rider [ __ ] yeah
why am i naked doesn't matter oh this
person is awesome I've seen this work
before it's like a template of a
PewDiePie or this is like a template of
a fighting game with the animation of
like the stuff it's so cool subscribe
and punch hey let's make that happen
and we finish off with animate another
amazing artwork Jesus Christ Bros I'm
blown away so funny so talented so
awesome I'm really impressed and I I
love doing these type of videos with you
because I don't know it's cool to do
something together and it means a lot to
me that you bros participating these so
thank you to everyone who submitted the
next challenge is going to be about my
beard susie bros seems to be so obsessed
with it go ahead do you love it do you
hate it roast my beard
are you hashtag Pete's beard or hashtag
peel shape the hashtag with more tweets
with when the hashtag where more tweets
will decide the fate of this beard now
go go forth my children tell the King
tell them about the beard
and as always stay awesome breasts like
videos of him while he plays a video
while he plays different video games but
then he throws like duck videos in
between look at that guy's face same
face my father had when I first showed
one of my videos and I like you you're
the best